foreign
welcome back so I couldn't help myself I have to
do another phase portrait this one is one of my
absolute favorite uh kind of dynamical systems to
play around with is the particle in this uh cortic
or fourth order potential well given by this
formula here my potential function is a fourth
order polynomial minus a second order polynomial
and again by Newton's Second Law we can write down
that the Dynamics X double dot are minus the
gradient of this potential so that should be a
positive X minus an X cubed so x minus X cubed
and I'm just going to put in a kind of almost
like air quotes here this optional you know minus
uh this is like an optional optional friction or
damping okay and so I'm actually going to draw
the phase portrait with and without friction
so you know at first we're going to ignore
this friction sorry this x dot this damping
or friction I'm going to draw the face portrait
and then I'm going to draw it again um with the
friction so I'm actually going to put my axes up
here because I think I need uh maybe I'll just put
okay good good yes
okay and I'm gonna draw my face
portrait X V and X V kind of uh without
friction and then I'm going to do it
again with friction so this is uh with
friction and these are going to make some super
cool pictures these are absolutely beautiful we've
actually made t-shirts my wife and I have made
t-shirts of the face portrait of this dynamical
system that's how cool it is okay good um and like
I do uh we're going to turn this into a system of
coupled first order equations instead of a second
order equation so we're going to introduce um
x dot equals V I probably shouldn't do pink here
it doesn't really matter I'm not going to do pink
here I'm going to do blue to stay consistent
so x dot equals V and V Dot equals x minus
X cubed and again there will be this optional
you know minus V term that we're going to add
and it's probably not minus V I might make this
minus 0.01 x dot or minus 0.01 V just so you can
draw your pictures a little bit more sensibly if
you actually want to do this at home okay um and
so what we do is we find our fixed points we find
the Jacobian the linearization of these non-linear
Dynamics at those fixed points and that tells me
locally what the Dynamics are going to look like
so again from first principles physics I know that
I'm going to have a fixed point at the top of this
hill if I put my particle or my bead okay we're
talking about a little particle that's rolling
around on this potential surface or a little bead
that's kind of sliding along this wire surface
here and so if I started at this point here
I would stay there forever it's a fixed point
now if I pushed it if I nudged it it's going to
roll off but if I was perfectly balanced that's
a fixed Point that's a fixed point and that's a
fixed point so I'm going to just draw these down
because we know already that they're going to look
like this probably shouldn't have gone all the way
down here but that's life okay and I'm just going
to write down what my fixed points are semi-fixed
points of course V is going to have to equal zero
for this to be a fixed point so V is always going
to have to equal zero and I know I have three
fixed points I'm just going to write them out um
in all of these cases V has to equal zero and if
V equals zero then x minus X cubed has to equal
zero so the easiest way for that to happen is
for X to equal zero that's definitely a fixed
point this is the x equals zero fixed point right
here so x equals 0 V equals 0 is a fixed point
but if x equals plus or minus 1 this also
equals zero so plus one and minus one plus
one and minus 1 are also fixed points this is
you know plus one this is minus one those are
also fixed points of X with velocity equal
to zero so those are our three fixed points
we compute our Jacobian matrix DF DX this is
my Vector field you know f of x and V so DF
with respect to um that Vector I call this uh I'm
calling this little x v stacked Vector X under bar
so the derivative of f with respect
to X is this Jacobian matrix
partial of the first equation with respect
to X is zero partial of the first equation
with respect to V is one partial of the
second equation with respect to X is
1 minus three x squared and partial of
the second equation with respect to V is
minus 1 if I have friction zero if I
don't okay it would be zero if I don't
have friction it would be minus one if I do
have friction or minus 0.01 or 0.001 whatever
I say the magnitude of this friction
term is is going to be what's down here
I shouldn't have smudged that
should not have smudged that okay
and now the last thing this is okay not so bad
I found my fixed points I computed the Jacobian
now I have to evaluate this Jacobian at each
of these fixed points and find the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors okay so I'm just going to uh to
write this down this is pretty simple so at the
zero zero point dfdx at um my zero zero point
is going to be 0 1 1 and again optionally if I
have friction a negative one here if not it'll
be zero and in either case we're going to get
saddle Dynamics for this point this point is
going to be a saddle okay which totally makes
sense because it's unstable if I nudge the system
it's going to go unstable uh and you could compute
it to eigenvectors and eigenvalues you know you
could do that and the eigenvectors are going to
be pointing in the 45 degree Direction with these
ones unstable and these ones stable I'm skipping
some steps you could you know do this in python
or Matlab or by hand to find these eigenvectors
and so these eigenvectors are pointing
in this direction here I know for these
mechanical F equals ma systems usually my
Saddles are in this 45 degree orientation
and then both of the other points actually
have exactly the same linearization Jacobian
because x squared whether I plug in plus one
or minus one this x squared is the same so dfdx
at either plus or minus 1 0 either
of those points is going to equal 0 1
and now one minus 3 is minus two and then again
this optional um you know friction could be here
or not and I really should have called this
like you know 0.01 x dot .01 V minus 0.01
minus 0.01 minus 0.01 I'm just lazy but when
you actually compute this use a small number
here so it doesn't botch your eigenvalues
too much and I'm going to claim that this
with no damping so with um with no damping
this is going to have plus or minus
um you know some constant eye you know some
number times I so this is going to be a center
a stable Center or with friction
it's going to be a spiral
sink with friction meaning I'm going to have like
a minus a plus or minus I for my eigenvalues I'm
going to have a negative real part plus or minus
I uh complex conjugate part with with damping
with friction and so now I'm actually ready to
draw these phase portraits so I'm going to start
with the no friction case because that'll be a lot
easier the without friction case where this fixed
Point these two fixed points are just pure centers
there's no friction so they just you know a little
particle is going to oscillate forever in these
Wells and so in that case these are going to be
concentric little circles and I'm pretty sure
that the direction of the arrows go here if I
remember from my last lecture they go like this
similarly um concentric circles here um like that
meaning that if I start with a little particle
that's a teeny bit up this well it's just going
to oscillate back and forth forever that's what
this XV diagram having a circle means is that
you know X is decreasing while V increases
then X in you know if I start here at um
zero velocity then X is going to move in the
right direction X is going to move in this
right direction and velocity is going to pick up
velocity is going to hit its maximum value here at
the fixed Point version of and where X is at the
fixed point and then it's going to overshoot X
is going to increase until V eventually is zero at
the top of this and then it's going to turn around
and do the same thing okay so these totally make
sense and down here the only thing that's going
to change is that now these centers are no longer
perfect circles they are going to kind of how do I
want to draw this they're going to you know spiral
inward like that and these guys are going to
um I don't want to draw it these guys are also
going to spiral inward like that that's the only
thing that's going to change but now again this
is all that I can say from the local linearization
from just taking these jacobians and evaluating
locally we're zooming in near these fixed points
where these non-linear Dynamics look linear and
this is what the local linearization looks like
the global structure because of the physics of
the system and usually I start with the saddle
point and I think to myself what happens if
I nudge this thing a teeny bit to the right
so it's basically going to roll down this
hill it's going to go up to the same height
here I'm just going to draw myself a line so I
don't mess up like last time same thing if I did
here if I nudged a teeny bit to the left it's
going to roll up this hill to the same height
and what that means is that this trajectory is
going to kind of go until X is at this point
here where I have zero velocity because
I've come to the same potential energy
then it's going to turn around and go right
back the way it came perfectly symmetrically
back like this and this is called the unstable
manifold of this fixed point because this is the
unstable Direction This is and it's curved
so it's a manifold and it attaches to the
stable manifold it'll kind of come back and
there's a perfect trajectory with a perfect
position and velocity that will roll right
up exactly to that fixed Point that's this
blue curve here similarly if I nudge it to the
left I get the same thing in Reverse like that
And the last piece I want to draw is... what if I
had my point here, but I pushed it with a bigger
velocity? I gave it like a big initial kick so I
start at this x location but at a big positive
velocity...  then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to overshoot to a farther point so I'm
going to overshoot to a farther point I'm going to
turn around and I'm going to pass right through my
fixed point with a negative velocity I'm going to
turn around and pass right through my fixed point
with a negative velocity and then I'm going to
overshoot to another point on the left and then
I'm going to repeat that forever and ever and ever
so this is another orbit where if I have a little
bit more energy than this fixed point I'm just
going to go around and around forever and ever
So this is the global orbit picture for
for this double potential well.
And when I add friction the only thing
that changes is that these stop being
perfect centers and they spiral in... they kind of
symmetry break and now they spiral in.
And now I believe that if I nudge my system from
this perfect fixed point, it will roll up to a
little bit less high, then it'll roll to a little
bit less high, and eventually it'll get trapped inthis well.
And, similarly if I kick it to the left
it'll eventually get trapped in this left well.
So if I kick it to the right I am going
to eventually kind of get sucked into
this well. If I kick it from the left I'm
eventually going to get sucked into this well.
And I get this kind of cool spiral pattern here...
and then you can continue these out just by logic,
it has to be like this, which I really like...
drawing this kind of candy cane stripe patternhere.
And so this actually segments phase space,
the x-v space, every single point...
every single point I start with eventually after friction, after
enough time, after it oscillates enough, will either
land and die in one of these wells, in this well or the
other well.
And so you can almost kind of reverse back and figure out all of the points that ended up
in this well. I'm just going to draw them in pink...
all of the points that ended up in this well here
form this stripe of the system... let's try not
to mess this up... this stripe here all of these
points will eventually end up in this left
well that I've drawn in pink. And all of these
points that I'm going to draw in blue -- I'm going to
just emanate outward from this blue point -- all of
these points are going to end up in the right well.
Does that make sense? So eventually there is
this whole kind of interesting candy stripe
landscape of points that will eventually go to
either the left well or the right well. So these
are called attracting basins, these two
basins of attraction, and all trajectories are
eventually going to end up at these two fixed
points. Very, very cool.
this is the one we made a t-shirt of... my wife made a really coolphotoshop of "the scream" face so let's
see if I can do this without botching
it too terribly... yeah "the scream" face
in the middle of phase space...
So no one can hear you screamin phase space.
All right so that's phase portraits.
This is one of my favorite dynamical systems
and you can do a lot of powerful stuff even for
very non-linear systems by finding the fixed
points, linearizing around the fixed points,
looking at the eigenvalues and eigenvectors,
and using your intuition andgeometry.
All right thank you.